yes a movie about a guy surviving a
world of giant insect monsters in the
name of love that is to say though this
is
nothing like monster hunter it's
probably more like monster hunter than
the actual monster hunter movie we're
getting so
good on this movie for accidentally
stumbling into that
[Music]
love and monsters so loving monsters is
you know it's a post-apocalyptic movie
otherwise known as
probably 2021 at this point civilization
has fallen we're no longer the top of
the food chain everybody lives in these
little colony bunkers
underground because insects lizards and
other creepy crawlies we just dealt with
with a boot or a can of raid or
for you vegans out there released back
into the wild
they've mutated and they've become
enormous at least as big as a house so
we just kind of need to hide from them
and dylan o'brien's like i'm going to
travel 80 miles to this other encampment
where my girlfriend
from before civilization fell so from a
few years ago is the only thing is dylan
o'brien's character
not really a survivalist will probably
not fare
so well on the surface he's a nerd he's
kind of a klutz
does not know how to take on a monster
yet he goes on his quest in the name
of love and i quite enjoyed myself in
this movie first of all dylan o'brien
guy is a charismatic actor he's one of
those actors even if he's in a movie
that's not so good
you can tell he's given 110 and i'm not
saying he's the only thing this movie
had going for there's actually a lot
that i did like about this movie
but if this movie didn't have dylan
o'brien as the lead
i probably wouldn't have enjoyed it as
much not only am i baffled just looking
at him i'm like this guy can
play an age range of 10 years probably
more he can play a 17 year old to a 30
year old and i'll just i'll believe it
that doesn't just come from
looks that comes from maturity of acting
prowess the guy is just
instantly relatable instantly likable
through some scenes in this movie i'm
like oh
you're hitting the emotion switch you're
you're turning on the works okay
didn't expect it when he gets emotional
in this movie you feel it when he cracks
a comedic joke of some sort you know
lightening the mood it doesn't
compromise the emotional tone and that's
something that movies these days
it's like they forgot how to do that and
while he's out there on the surface he
runs across a couple of friends first of
all though the creature designs are
actually pretty rad because you know
what animal you're looking at
but it's a mutated version of it so it's
slightly different
also much more enormous but i enjoy the
couple of friends he runs across he runs
across
his little girl palling around with this
apocalypse survivor guy played by
michael rooker so
of course he plays that it's michael
rooker he's always a variant
of michael rooker being michael in fact
i don't even know he knew he was being
filmed to be honest with you this guy
when john schnepp did comic book
shopping with michael rooker michael
rooker proceeded to show him different
ways to kill a person i mean to be fair
all self-defense scenarios but still
michael rooker actually
effectively knows creative ways to
dispatch
anyone who would try to do him harm and
i'm not even the least bit surprised
that that's reality how could you not
have him in this movie anyhow i enjoyed
his character and he's the one who
shows our lady shows dylan o'brien's
character the ropes like okay look out
for this watch out for this his monsters
act like this his monsters
act like that but the most important
friend he finds
is a dog the dog's name is boy boy is so
important to this movie because
i mean first of all it's a dog in the
apocalypse i think about that sometimes
like okay the apocalypse happens how's
it gonna go down my dogs are such
bark machines i'm like we'll probably
die very quickly
but we'll die together can't just leave
your dogs come on but that's what this
dog feels like this dog is
family and this dog leads to some
intense moments and this isn't
a monster movie with people in it in
which the people
feel like they're taken away from the
monsters from the get-go it establishes
this
is a movie about the human beings the
monsters are secondary
and they don't overplay the monsters
they don't throw too many monsters on
screen which means when the monsters do
show up it feels special
and it always feels intense you have too
many monsters like okay yeah let's just
escape evade or take out another one but
when one shows up it's business you're
white knuckling it it feels intense it
feels
as intense as it does because he has
something to lose other than himself
and that is his dog if the dog wasn't in
this movie it would have changed the
entire dynamic of the movie changed the
vibe of the movie and i wouldn't have
been
as attached to the movie dylan o'brien
and the dog
make the movie i firmly believe that
having the dog in this movie was
a brilliant call all this is to say i
had a really good time with love and
monsters in a world where i didn't know
what love and monsters was about i
thought it was going to be love and
monsters like halloween monsters no i
feel like my horror review extravaganza
kind of got away from me this week where
i was like hey
nope that's not really halloweenish
loving that's not really halloweenish
either we'll get back on track next week
in the end this
this movie was a proper movie of
character growth
you're there with dylan o'brien's
character you're there to see him grow
and he does
again it's like something lightly movies
you've just kind of forgotten how to do
that i mean not always
but enough for me to address it here and
it's inspiring you know like proper
inspiration i was looking at this
character at the end i'm like
this is a character that actually does
inspire people not just someone who was
badass always badass always will be
badass all right now i'm the leader but
no a character like this
that's an inspirational character to me
it's a coming-of-age movie
about love family human connection and
the better connection than human
connection which is human connection
and a dog i feel like i'm actually gonna
buy this one it's worth watching and
worth buying on blu-ray i mean you rent
it right now for 20 bucks which seems
kind of steep
five more bucks you get it digitally do
what you want just saying i really
enjoyed the movie all right so love and
monsters have you seen it what did you
think about it i saw it on amazon
i don't know if that's the only place to
watch it but that's where i saw it i
have been told in the comment section
people would like to know where to find
these movies so there you go what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite monster movie of all time
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you